Olá, minhas queridas, meus queridos.
Sejam muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live dos apoiadores.
É um grande prazer tê-los comigo
e vamos diretamente
às dúvidas. Mas antes, deixa eu dar um
alô para vocês.
Boa noite, Patrícia de Bragança.
Boa noite, Rinaldo.
Boa noite, Vilma.
Boa noite, querida Alice Vogel.
Boa noite, Dra. Ana Paula.
À medida que vocês forem entrando, por
favor, vão dando o seu alô.
Vamos à apresentação.
Qual é a dose vizetina para desinflamar
o corpo?
A dose
pode variar 100 a 500 mg por dia.
Então essa é a faixa que a maioria dos
estudos científicos utilizou.
E é muito importante utilizar junto com
a refeição rica em gordura para aumentar
a absorção. É o caso do abacate, óleo de
coco, azeite de oliva.
Existem estudos usando doses mais altas,
mas é um ativo um pouco caro.
Tem estudo aí até com 1,5 g ao dia.
Então a fizetina é um ativo muito
interessante, né? Porque ele tem a
propriedade de matar as células
senescentes. Então é um agente
senolítico.
Ele tem uma ação antiflamatória, ele
baixa os marcadores delocina 6, TNF
alfa.
Inibe NFK beta.
O uso entre 8 a 12 semanas
e com acompanhamento médico. É muito bom
para pessoas também que têm doenças
autoimunes.
Qual é o melhor tratamento para zumbido
no ouvido?
Isso depende muito da causa. É muito
importante entender o que tá levando ao
zumbido.
Existe aí alguns recursos interessantes.
Eu uso muito gincobila,
eu uso muito agentes que aumentam o
óxido nítrico, como é a caso
da arginina,
como é o caso do inibidor da arginase.
Eu uso bastante também
substâncias que aumenta a a circulação
cerebral
para ajudar nisso aí, como é o caso da
vimbocetina.
Agora existe uma literatura mais recente
mostrando sobre a terapia a laser de
baixa intensidade
e a laser pura são bem interessantes
para essas condições de zumbido,
especialmente quando te associa com
terapia vácuo e os de cubiloba, que eu
já comentei.
Existe também um dispositivo de
neuromodulação bimodal que foi aprovado
nos Estados Unidos, é o Lenire.
Lenire, ele utiliza estimulação auditiva
e estimulação na língua. Bem
interessante. Tem tido ótimas respostas,
80% de redução na gravidade do zumbido.
Muito importante tirar os fatores
inflamatórios,
reduzir o estresse, reduzir o café,
reduzir o álcool. Muita gente tem esse
problema por conta também de excesso de
ruído durante a vida. Então tem que ter
esse cuidado também de preservar os
ouvidos do excesso de barulho.
Tem pessoas que tm disfunção na
articulação tempor mandibulac que acabam
desenvolvendo também o zumbido.
Além de investigar a causa com otorrino,
é muito importante então adotar uma
dieta antiinflamatória, atividade física
regular,
muita água, cortar o café em excesso e o
álcool e fazer o tratamento que eu já
comentei.
Boa noite. Faz mal comer ovos todos os
dias? De jeito nenhum. Eu como no mínimo
três ovos por dia. Tem dia que eu como
seis, até mais.
Não é verdade. É mito que já foi
derrubado, que o ovo faz mal paraa
saúde.
Ele é o polivitamínico da natureza, um
alimento extraordinariamente
nutritivo,
muita proteína, vitaminas em gerais,
minerais, gorduras saudáveis, ajuda da
saciedade a controlar o peso, ajuda no
ganho de massa muscular, fortalece o
tema imune, beneficia a pele. O
colesterol do ovo não tem nenhum tipo de
impacto no organismo. 80 a 90% do
colesterol que nós temos é produção
interna do organismo que precisa de
matériapra.
Então o problema não é produção de
colesterol e nem o colesterol da dieta,
o problema é a oxidação do LDL, que é
ocasionada aí por hábitos ruins de vida
e exposição a toxinas ambientais.
E o próprio ovo tem vários antioxidantes
que ajudam a evitar a oxidação do LDL.
Então não faz sentido realmente evitar o
ovo por causa do colesterol.
Então, muita gente tem medo de comer
ovo, mas tem fisiculturistas aí, não que
fisiculturista seja exemplo para
ninguém, mas que come aí dezenas de ovos
por dia. Eu diria para comer entre três
a cinco ovos é tranquilo.
Existe uma discussão sobre a colina e o
TMAO, né? Então tem uma discussão já tem
uns anos que se você comesse muita
colina você poderia aumentar essa
substância do sangue. O TMAO que seria
uma substância que geraria aumento de
risco de infarto.
Então essa questão, o que que eu diria?
Por precaução, não coma mais de 10 ovos
por dia por conta da questão do do TMAO.
A corina é metabolizada
pelas bactérias intestinais TMA, é
absorvida e no sangue vira TMAO. Então o
que que eu digo para vocês? Não como
mais de 10 por dia, apesar disso ser um
material que ainda é muito polêmico.
No geral, acho que isso nem é um grande
problema.
Doutor Alan, NAC e Liteanina à noite tem
alguma sinergia?
É uma boa pergunta. O NAC, ele é o
precursor da gluta?
A eliteanina é um grande calmante
natural que aumenta a calma focada.
A eliteanina à noite vai reduzir o
glutamato em excesso, que é o
neurotransmissão excitatória, vai ajudar
a aumentar o gaba. Então, a litenina
aumenta o gaba, que é o neurotransmissor
calmante, e modula também serotonina e
dopamina.
Então o próprio NAC também tem uma ação
de antagonizar o glutamato.
Então ele vai ajudar o GLC, vai ajudar a
litanina a atuar,
além de ser ele mesmo precursor da gluta
que é o principal enzima antioxidante.
fazer essa associação então é totalmente
segura e faz sentido.
NC entre 600 e 1200 mg por dia. Ele tem
anina entre 200 a 400 mg por dia.
É melhor tomar uma hora antes de deitar
se o
se a questão é melhorar o sono.
Magnésio poderia ser uma excelente
adição. Glicina também. fizetina que nós
comentamos agora,
a pigenina ajuda no sono.
Então tem muita coisa que pode tomar à
noite para ajudar no sono.
Tem um lipo A 277. Será que é isso
mesmo? É porque o pessoal confunde
apolipoproteína A1 com lipoproteína A,
tá? Então vamos entender que a pessoa
não confundiu.
Estou com quatro pontos de obstrução nas
coronárias, então deve ser lipo mesmo.
HDL sempre foi 30. Minha irmã tem lipo
de 394. Muito alto, hein? HDL58 não tem
nada. Será que é lipo ou é a ausência de
níveis adequados de HDL? No seu caso, o
HDL com certeza seria protetor. Mas é
difícil baixar LPA.
É difícil. Eu tô na dúvida até agora se
você tá falando de LPA ou de
poliproteína um, mas deve ser LPA. Tinha
gordura no fígado, hoje tá controlado.
Então, como eu já disse em vídeos
anteriores, a LPA é um fator de risco
independente paraa doença arterial
coronariana ou pra doença arterial
cerebral.
Então, como a sua irmã tem um HDL maior,
isso atua como um fator protetor.
E no seu caso, você não tem esse fator
protetor, seu HDL é baixo.
Tem estudos recentes do UK Biobank
mostrando que o risco cardiovascular
aumenta linearmente com cada incremento
de LPA e o HDL consegue bloquear
parcialmente. Ele desempenha um papel
crucial. um sistema fibrinolítico.
Então, o que que eu diria para você?
Muito bom se ter perdido a gordura no
fígado. Isso aí é irrelevante, faz a
diferença.
Isso vai ajudar a baixar a resistência
insulínica, informação sistêmica e vai
reduzir a oxidação do LDL.
Aumente seu HDL naturalmente com
ômega-3. Tome pelo menos três cápsulas
de ômega-3 de alta qualidade, faça
exercício físico intenso com esquema
de intensidade, né, modulada. Aquele
esquema
me fugiu agora a sigla, mas eu acho que
você sabe o que eu tô falando. Aquele
esquema que você vai aumentando a
intensidade e reduzindo a intensidade.
High intensity
eh interval é o é como é que é? High
intensity H e esqueci agora a sigla.
Enfim, vocês estão entendendo.
E use aacina
de liberação eh [ __ ] para baixar o
LPA. Use L carnitina. Eu tenho um vídeo
agora que eu não lembro agora se saiu,
se vai sair, que é sobre esse assunto
que vai tá na parte aberta do canal.
Então, niacina é muito importante, só
que neacina daquele flush. Então, para
evitar o flush, usa neacina de liberação
[ __ ] ou o exenontinato de noositol.
Só que tem alguns estudos que falam que
o exaninado de noosital tem menos ação
do que aina
metros de liberação
prolongada.
Eh, boa noite, Patrícia de Barraagança.
Isso. Ana Dra. Paulo colocou aqui é o
hit, o high intensity training interval.
É o hit.
Paulo tá escrevendo tudo bonitinho aqui.
Então, tem várias coisas que a gente
pode fazer para ajudar na questão do LPA
aí, tá? Tem um protocolo bem completo.
Eu acredito que ele tá num documento,
tá? Se não tiver, vocês me cobram depois
que eu coloco, OK?
Para tomar demencio, preciso ficar sem
alimento como dióxido.
É possível usar magnésio vegetável no
Brasil? Se sim, quais os critérios?
Magnésio a gente faz o tempo todo, tá? A
gente faz na clínica, não tem problema
nenhum, não é proibido não.
E para tomar demência para você ficar
sem alimento. A, quer esse jejum? Isso.
Vocês confundem muito DMSO com
com CDS, com MMS, né? E além e também
com MSM.
Ah, não tem essa necessidade de ficar de
jejum, não. Mas o DMSO para uso oral ele
é off label, digamos assim, tá? Não é um
uso oficial, ele só é oficial
na pele. Para uso oral você pode
utilizar, mas as fontes oficiais não
recomendam.
Então, geralmente para magnésio a gente
usa o sulfeto de magnésio ou sulfato de
magnésio endovenoso e o cloreto de
magnésio a gente faz entrar um ccular.
Então, talvez você tá falando do
magnésio porque teve uma história que
Anvisa suspendeu nos últimos tempos
alguns suplementos com magnésio tronato
de malato queelado, mas isso eram
problemas de empresas específicas, tá?
não tem nenhum tipo de
proibição de usar magnésio endovenoso.
Pelo contrário, se usa magnésio até em
hospital ortodoxo o tempo todo, por
exemplo, para evitar eclâmpia e mulher
gestante para repor magnésio e paciente
internado. Então não tem nada de
irregular usar magnésio, não.
Boa noite. Qual seria a dosagem ideal do
piquinogenol para prevenção de
trombofilia?
A gente usa o piquinogenol entre 100 a
200 mg por dia. É uma dose muito boa.
Geralmente eu uso ele em associação
comatoquinase. É uma ótima associação.
Tem estudos mostrando ação significativa
na prevenção de trombose, na melhora de
saúde arterial, efeito antioxidante,
efeito cerebral.
tem uma incidência de efeitos colaterais
muito inferior aos remédios
antistrobóticos normais.
A dose máxima recomendada é 400 mg por
dia.
Então comece com 100 mg e depois se
tiver tudo bem a para 200 mg por dia.
Você pode tomar uma dose de manhã, uma
dose à noite. E evite de tomar em jejum
que ele pode dar desconforto gástrico se
você tomar em jejum.
Dut Alan, extratos Pinheira Santa,
cápsula de 500 seria o ideal para tratar
desconforto gastrointestinal? Sim, é um
dos ativos que eu mais uso para isso, já
que entre diversas indicações, uma seria
a reestruturação do muco. Sim, concordo.
Geralmente eu uso espinheira santa junto
com mucosave,
junto com licor DGL e junto com zinco
carnosina. E se tiver guaçatonga, a
gente acrescenta também.
Então a espinheira tem taninos que vão
promover um efeito antiúlcera,
um efeito cicatrizante na mucosa
gástrica. Também ajuda a controlar a
acidez e protege o revestimento do
estômago.
Pode usar até três vezes ao dia, tá? Se
você for utilizar esse primeira santa
isolado,
então se conseguir lembrar que a maioria
dos pacientes não lembra de tomar três
vezes ao dia.
Lembrar que muitos casos de refluxo é
causado pelo glúten e por leite
derivados. Então, se for fazer esse
tratamento, corte, glúten, leite e
derivados e os alimentos inflamatórios.
Vi um vídeo de um profissional da saúde
que um dos benefícios do Lugol é remover
os metais pesados dos tecidos moles,
porém que deveria ser associado à titura
de coentro ou zeita,
pois sem associação a esses metais
ficariam na corrente sanguínea. Procede
sim. O iodo tem uma ação que quel tão
forte quanto
o próprio Zeólita.
Então tem que ter isso em mente.
É interessante associar mais um
queelante, isso vai aumentar o detox de
uma maneira segura.
Agora não tem essa informação que se
você usar o Lugol sozinho,
você vai ter a situação de o metal ficar
na corrente sanguínea e não ser
eliminado, não. Na verdade, ele vai
funcionar também sem o Zór e sem o
Penton, mas é uma boa ideia associar.
Tem casos que inclusive a gente utiliza
o DMSA,
o DTPA, que são quilantes mais oficiais,
digamos assim,
além do próprio DTA.
Existem comprovações de benefício do
escalapé? Sim. Quais são eles e como
fazer corretamente?
Sim, tem melhoras da circulação
sanguínea periférica porque faz vaso
dilatação, reduz estresse, reduz
ansiedade, promove relaxamento muscular
profundo, alivia as dores musculares e
inflamações, reduz inchaços, retenção de
líquidos, melhora a qualidade do sono,
alivia cólica menstrual,
pode ser também uma maneira de você
estimular pontos de reflexologia no pé.
pode ajudar no controle da pressão
e não tem nada a ver com detox, tá? É
uma questão de vaso de dilatação.
Pode associar sal depson, que é uma
forma de magnésio, sulfato de magnésio,
ervas como camomila e lavanda. Pode
colocar óleos essenciais, é bem
interessante.
Pode fazer massagem, movimentos
circulares durante a imersão com as
mãos.
Pode acontecer
efeitos colaterais do escaldapés
para pessoas com pressão alta, trombose
ou câncer com metástase. Então, cuidado
nesses casos. gestantes também devem
tomar um certo cuidado.
Aproveito para parabenizá-lo pelo
trabalho ímpar que faz. Obrigado. Pois
além de conhecimento, tem que ter
coragem. É verdade. É imensurável o
número de pessoas beneficiadas direta e
indiretamente. Eu agradeço as suas
palavras gentis.
Ômega-3 vem cápsulas oleosas. Sim, mesmo
assim deve ser tomado junto com a
refeição gudurosa. Não, não precisa. O
ômeega-3 é a própria gordura, não tem
necessidade de associar ele com comida.
O que a gente faz às vezes é associar o
omega-3 com vitamina D ou outros
alimentos lipossolúveis. É o caso da
cúrcuma ou curcumina, é o caso de vários
carotenoides
que são liposolúveis. Então o ômega-3
não depende de nada para absorver, mas é
bom associar ômega-3 com outros
elementos que são lipossolúveis, como
vitaminas lipossolúveis, vitamina D3,
K2,
a cúrcuma, como eu falei.
Agora é uma boa ideia sim associar o
ômega-3 com alimentação, com gordura.
Isso vai ajudar na absorção, apesar de
não ser obrigatório. OK?
Existe alguns estudos também que sugerem
você tomar ômega-3 num jantar para
potencializar
a ação dele com uma síntese de
melatonina à noite. OK? Tem essa
história também.
O excesso de proteína consumida na dieta
carnívora é armazenada ou eliminada?
Não. A proteína ela é convertida em
aminoácidos.
Se você tiver algum problema no
intestino, uma disbiose,
uma síndrome síndrome desabsortiva, por
exemplo, pode acontecer dessa carne
apodrecer no seu intestino e nem ser
absorvida e nem ser digerida. Mas
geralmente é dirigida sim, vira
aminoácidos ou peptídios curtos, né, de
três ou quatro aminoácidos.
E esses aminoácidos que são absorvidos e
não são utilizados, eles passam por uma
metabolização
nitrogenada, né, e são eliminadas na
urina e
parte pelas feeses.
Pode acontecer também de parte desses
aminoácidos virarem glicose pela
neoglicogênese
e depois ir pro fígado e ser convertido
em gordura.
E aí o subproduto da metabolização dos
aminoácidos
vão virar urea, vão virar outros
metabólos nitrogenados, vão ser
filtrados pelo rim, eliminados pela
urina. Se a pessoa tiver função renal já
alterada,
pode haver uma sobrecarga no rim e isso
contribui paraa piora da função renal
quando já tem uma lesão nesse órgão.
Se você tá ingerindo por volta de 1,3 a
1,7 g por kg dia, lembrando que 1 kg de
carne não é 1 kg de proteína,
você não vai estar com excesso de
minuácido. Agora, se você comer uma
quantidade absurda de minuáculo,
a além da sua capacidade de metabolizar,
você pode sim promover uma sobrecarga
renal,
apesar disso não ser muito comum isso.
E é muitoidade física para você
aproveitar esse abidão ácido da maneira
adequada. Então a questão aí não é essa
dieta carnívora ou não, é a quantidade
de proteína que você vai ingerir, se for
excessiva, pode ser sim prejudicial pra
saúde.
Então aminoácido pode virar energia,
pode virar matériapra por organismo e
pode ser escretado na urina se tiver em
excesso e sobrecarregar o rim.
Deixar frutas e legumes em água oonizada
reduz agrotóxicos? Sim, reduz. Não reduz
tudo.
Estudos falam que em torno de 70% de
redução não é 100%.
Então, vale muito a pena, apesar de não
remover todo o agrotóxico.
O ozônio, como é um agente oxidante,
ele é três vezes mais rápido
do que o cloro na eliminação de
microrganismos e também de toxinas.
E o ozônio também tem a vantagem de
tirar bactérias, vírus e fungos dos
alimentos e também não vai
adulterar as características
nutricionais,
pode prolongar a durabilidade dos
alimentos devido a essas
características.
Então você coloca 2 a 3 L de água
ozonizada,
imerge os alimentos lá, deixa 30 minutos
e depois remove. Isso no caso de legumes
e frutas.
Então, seria uma ótima estratégia, sim,
para reduzir agrotóxicos e reduzir
microorganismos e aumentar o tempo de
vida do alimento.
E se descascarmos as frutas e legumes
antes de higienizá-los, a redução de
agrotóx?
Creio que não, porque o problema não é a
superfície, é a parte interna do
alimento.
Agora, obviamente, se você remover a
casca e não comer a casca, você vai
deixar de comer parte do alimento e vai
reduzir dessa maneira, né?
Tem uma categoria de agrotóxicos que
penetram os tecidos e não tem jeito, não
vai remover com nem com lugol, nem com
ozônio, nem com nada, nem com iodo, nem
com água sanitária,
com cloro, entendeu?
Aí não tem jeito, ele não vai remover
100% entre 50 e 70%.
Ah, tem a técnica de bicarbonato também,
né, que também ajuda a tirar o o
agrotóxico,
tá bom? Mas isso são todas técnicas que
reduzem o problema e não eliminam,
infelizmente.
Quais são os prejuízos da ingestão do
emulsificante E471?
Esse produto, ele é usado amplamente em
produtos de panificação e alimentos
processados. É mais um problema, né? É
também conhecido como monoesterato de
glicerila.
Alguns órgãos dizem que ele é seguro em
pequenas quantidades, mas tem estudos
recentes que mostram uma associação dele
com aumento de risco cardiovascular e
cérebrovascular. É mais uma razão para
não comer alimento processado, né? se
não tivesse já umas 15,
altera também a microbiota intestinal,
torna a microbiota mais inflamatória,
vai contribuir pro liquigante ou
intestino vazante ou hiperpermeável.
Muito importante evitar então esses
emulsificantes
como alimentos naturais de preferência
orgânicos.
Seria menos pior a ingestão do que do
glúten.
São mecanismos diferentes, né?
O glúten, ele vai abrir a barreira
intestinal também, além do
emulsificante.
Só que
esse mulcificante tem essas evidências
de aumento de risco cardiovascular
e doença arterial.
E o glúten, o problema é mais de doença
autoimune.
Só que ambos vão também alterar o
microbioma intestinal.
Na verdade, elimine os dois da dieta,
né? Não é uma questão de ser o menos
pior ou o menos ruim ou enfim.
A arterosclerose é uma doença autoimune.
Qual o melhor tratamento? Não. Eh, ela é
parcialmente uma doença relacionada à
resposta imune. Sim, porque ela começa
através de macrófagos que se infiltram
na parede da artéria, no endotélio
tentando limpar o endotélio
eh de cálcio,
de cálcio, não, de LDL oxidado. A
calciicação vem depois. Então é uma
tentativa do sistema imune de limpar a
parede do endotélio do LDL oxidado.
Então ela não é classificada como
autoimun primária, mas sim no cerne da
doença tem um processo inflamatório que
o sistema imune participa.
Doenças autoimunes que são classificados
dessa maneira, como é o caso da artrite
hematóde, lupus, jogren, dematomioite,
etc., podem acelerar esse processo
aterogênico,
mas a aterosclerose em si não é
considerado autoimune. Mas sim o sistema
imune, como eu disse, participa do
processo.
O melhor tratamento é você prevenir a
tresclerose com alimentação limpa de
alimentos inflamatórios,
cortar os processados industrializados,
glúten leite derivados,
consumir alimentos ricos e antioxidantes
com vitamina E, C, E, A, selênio,
polifenóis,
é o caso polifenol que tem nazeite de
oliva
de alta qualidade.
Cuidado da comema Q10, da vitamina D
ômega-3, exercícios regulares, controle
do stress, controle do sono,
não ficar com pressão alta, não ficar
com glicose do sangue alterada demais,
não ter marcadores inflamatórios no
sangue, parar de fumar, controlar o
etilismo,
tá? Tudo isso é importante.
Deixa eu ver se tem perguntas ao vivo.
Dra. Ana Paula tá que tá aqui me
ajudando para caramba aqui, tocando o
pau aqui nas orientações aqui. Deixa eu
ver aqui.
Deixa eu ver se tem alguma coisa para
mostrar na tela aqui.
Aqui quando se deve usar a espermidina,
quando você quer aumentar os efeitos do
jejum intermitente, quando você quer
efeito antioxidante, antiinflamatório,
efeito antienolítico,
mas não é anticenolítico, é senolítico.
OK?
Aliás, deixa eu colocar sozinho. Pronto.
Ah,
Paulo escrevendo várias coisas
interessção
severa em mulher de 48 anos menopausada.
já utiliza o magnésio. Qual probiótico
poderia auxiliar?
Tem vários.
Lactobacilos
helt, lactobacilos
infantes, bistobactério, bífidum, tem um
vários que pode ajudar,
tá bom?
Tem um probiótico, um p de probióticos
que você pode pegar na manipulação,
chama test booster, que eu gosto muito,
tá?
Paulo, lembrando da homoína como
marcador importante de ateromatose. Esse
negócio que deixa meu cabelo meio
bagunçado. Deixa eu ver se eu arrumo
aqui. Pronto.
Mais ou menos. Você precisa cortar o
cabelo já.
É, o sulfato de magnésio pode ser
endovenoso intramuscular. É, o cloreto
de magnésio não pode ser endovenoso.
Ó, aí comentários e mais comentários.
Bom, Dr. Ana Paula, boa noite. Boa
noite.
Olha só. Verdade. Tem que lembrar que o
diabético perde sensibilidade.
Eu mantenho entre 40 e 70 a vitamina D
do sangue, tá, Marine? independente de
ser transplantado renal ou não.
Agora não deixarei acima de
70 ou não.
Deixa eu ver se tem mais alguma pergunta
que eu preciso posso ter perdido aqui.
Perguntando se é melhor ovos fritos ou
cozidos. Ambos são bons, com tanto que
você use um óleo bom para fritar, um
óleo de alta qualidade. Tá bom? T Paulas
até respondeu aqui, ó.
Qual pro Ah, já respondi também o teste
booster. Eu acho que já foi tudo, né,
pessoal? Vocês não tm mais eh
dúvidas não, né? Vou esperar mais um
minuto e vou encerrar.
Vou aguardar aqui. M.
Bem, pessoal, acho que é isso, né? Muito
obrigado pela presença de vocês.
Nós nos vemos para quem for do grupo de
estudos avançados. no próximo domingo,
senão até semana que vem. Um abraço a
todos.